well let's look at the west uh as john  morant got that he was second by the  players he was second by the fans and  second by the media  third by the players was devin booker  luca donchic was fourth  in their balloting so there you have it  you know it's interesting  because  [Music]  drama run is so exciting to watch  but i get spoiled watching devin booker  play  because i live in arizona  i mean i've heard that it's going to be  it's going to be crazy for the next 10  years  who gets i mean they're going to make  the all-star team but you always want to  start  you always want to start but it's going  to be very interesting that the guards  for the next 10 years they're locked in  they're locked in in the western car  yeah